it is holy thursday in pope francis
celebrated mask at st
peter's basilica in the vatican this
morning there were fewer attendees than
usual and they were masked and socially
distanced as we're supposed to do
this is the second year that the
coronavirus has disrupted easter
celebrations
chris livesay is in rome looking back at
the year of covet and the toll it's
taken on the vatican
chris good morning to you even the
vatican has been affected by all of this
good morning gail yes this is not the
holy week that pope francis wanted
speaking on palm sunday he said that the
devil himself
was taking advantage of the pandemic
which for now two years in a row
is taking a toll not just on people's
lives but also on church collection
plates
he's long been called the people's pope
but since the pandemic
he's been the pope with no people and
pontiff or not
it's the virus that still reigns at the
vatican during holy week
more than a year after the outbreak
first exploded in italy
especially painful for the pope the
absence of pilgrims
during what's normally the busiest week
at the vatican
in the past year diminishing donations
and closures at the vatican museums
have left a hole that's both spiritual
and financial
says cbs news vatican contributor
monsignor anthony figueredo
2020 million dollar shortfall
25 less revenues
it's led to even the cardinals having a
cut
in their salaries of 10
so there is real concern because we have
both the fall
in numbers in catholics a loss of
credibility for the church because of
the sexual abuse crisis
and now the pandemic it's like being in
a boxing ring and not knowing
where the next punch is coming from
but the pandemic didn't stop francis
from taking a
daring visit last month to iraq the
first
ever for a pope praying in churches once
ransacked by isis
and gathering with thousands of people
like we haven't seen
in a year all made possible by the covid
vaccine
for him and his entourage this week the
vatican is paying it forward
vaccinating 1200 poor and homeless
many from around st peter's square among
the rare
few who can actually be here during holy
week
he understands that not being able to go
to his flock is going to have long-term
consequences
will they come back that's the big
challenge
[Music]
and one more victim of kovid the pope's
washing of the feet which would
traditionally take place today he would
do that with the poor and the destitute
it's just
one more event that's been canceled but
we know that pope francis is
desperate to get out amongst the people
and vatican watchers tell us
we may still be in for a surprise tony
all right we'll be watching chris let's
say in rome chris thank you very much